c'est sûr qu'on fait tout pour croire à
ce qu'on joue donc on peut se laisser
aller aux sentiments du personnage c'est
possible
bienvenue Charlotte pour votre première
tout le monde en parle alors Claude
Miller a dit en parlant de vous
charlotte est une actrice née comme
Mozart était un musicien né
en tout cas à nouveau dans le film Ma
femme est une actrice réalisée par votre
compagnon j'aime bien ce mot compagnon
moi
Yvan Attal avec Terence temple Noémie
lowski qui est magnifique dans le film
qui est très très drôle magnifique
Laurent bateau et Lionel Abelanski que
de très bons acteurs alors vous dites en
tournant ce film j'avais l'impression de
faire du cinéma pour la première fois de
ma vie et c'est assez paradoxal puisque
vous jouez pratiquement votre propre
rôle dans le film celui d'une actrice
prénommée Charlotte et ils vont attaque
vie avec vous bien entendu dans la vraie
vie comme dans le film la seule
différence c'est qu'il est journaliste
sportif alors pourquoi cette impression
de faire du cinéma pour la première fois
parce que je l'ai vécu comme comme un
premier film parce que je l'ai
accompagné pendant pendant toutes les
écritures et sans participer mais je
l'ai vu à toutes les étapes et j'avais
le trac comme si c'était mon premier
film alors le pitch ça part d'un cours
métrage qui avait fait ils vont attaque
qui s'appelait woman et finalement qu'il
a transformé avec l'aide de Claude Berry
le producteur en un long métrage alors
c'est l'histoire d'un mec jaloux qui
supporte pas de vivre avec une actrice
parce qu'elle embrasse pour de faux bien
sûr mais bon
des mecs toute la journée et que parfois
pour de faux bien sûr mais bon elle
couche avec eux donc effectivement il
apprécie pas du tout il supporte pas ça
le rend carrément cinglé cette histoire
non ça le rend très jaloux très jaloux
mais il est d'un tempérament jaloux
enfin le personnage et la tempérament
jaloux dès le départ
très enlevée très bien éclairée bien
réalisé bien monté c'est un bonheur ça
va marcher moi je vous dis un truc les
Américains vont racheter l'histoire pour
faire
le remake alors ça peut pas être Tom
Cruise et Nicole Kidman parce qu'ils
sont plus ensemble mais pourquoi pas
ma femme est une actrice de Yvan Attal
avec Yvan attaque et Charlotte
Gainsbourg
c'est l'histoire un peu vraie d'ailleurs
parce qu'inspiré d'une aventure vécue
puisque quand vous faisiez l'homme etc
avec Marion vers nous il était copain
avec Charles Berling et le jour où
l'histoire dans le scénario l'histoire
c'est un peu
approfondie entre berline et vous il
avait plus envie de boire des verres
avec lui après le tournage
croire à ce qu'on joue donc on peut se
laisser aller au sentiment du personnage
c'est possible mais c'est vrai
qu'au-delà des rapports tactiles
c'est-à-dire se toucher se serrer dans
les bras s'embrasser être dans le même
lit il y a quand même des rapports de
séduction des rapports amoureux quand on
joue avec quelqu'un
le plus dangereux c'est pas forcément
les les
scènes
non non pas forcément
sur les plateaux il y avait un climat
aphrodisiaque c'est pour ça qu'ils
surveillait ta mère sur la piscine
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
propice à on est fragilisé sur un sur un
plateau de tournage donc on est plus
sensible et c'est vrai qu'on se font un
peu dans les sentiments qu'on doit
éprouver d'ailleurs il y a une scène qui
est très bien dans le film en question
dans ma famille est une actrice c'est
quand vous êtes en train de jouer aux
échecs dans la caravane de tournage avec
Terence Stan et que
Ivan arrive effectivement on voit bien
ce qui se passe pas en train de coucher
avec lui mais vous êtes dans son
intimité quand même vous êtes dans une
intimité avec terrains on comprend bien
pourtant il y a pas de geste il y a rien
oui c'est vrai je suis gênée parce que
je suis
sûrement
arriver il y a pas toujours des
histoires d'amour sur tous les les
plateaux de tournage mais puis on vit
c'est une vie intense pendant quelques
mois
c'est une aventure alors d'ailleurs ils
vont attaque vous l'avez rencontré en
1990 au tournage de aux yeux du monde le
film d'Éric Rochant donc si tu es arrivé
une fois ça peut encore arriver en même
temps
pour le moment ça va avec Yvan
tout va bien ça a l'air très amoureux
l'un de l'autre quand on vous voit
ensemble je sais pas et votre enfant ben
va bien est-ce qu'il est circoncis cet
enfant parce que
dans le film c'est un des grands sujets
avec un gars un non juif et elle veut
absolument faire circoncire son fils et
lui veut pas et c'est très bien c'est
très bien raconté c'est très rigolo
ouais ouais c'était un sujet qui me
touchait mais
vous avez fait quoi vous laissez
circonscient votre fils
vous êtes toujours été très attiré par
la religion juive bien que n'étaient pas
juive puisque votre mère ne l'est pas
mais j'étais toujours fait très attirés
oui j'ai eu un j'ai eu une attirance à
l'âge où ça arrive genre à l'adolescence
vous vous avez pas souffert de ma mère
est une actrice où mon père est un
chanteur je n'ai pas souffert de ça je
crois pas je crois que je me suis même
pas posé la question c'était comme ça et
non je crois pas que j'en ai sous ça
pour tous les enfants
c'est-à-dire que elle son père l'emmener
comme ça dans les dans les boîtes de
nuit à l'âge de peut-être pas de deux
ans mais enfin les gens là de 5-6 ans et
vous pareil il y a deux ans vous étiez
dans les boîtes ils ont dormi sur des
banquettes
ça s'est bien passé ils ont gardé un bon
souvenir
très bon j'en avais une vie à la fois
très stable et
un peu folle parce qu'on les suivait
vous êtes sur un plateau c'est le
plateau de la pirate qui est réalisé par
votre beau-père Jacques Doyon et Jane
Birkin dit à ce moment-là vous avez
porté sur l'actrice leur Marsac un
regard de jalousie est-ce que c'était
une envie d'être actrice ou est-ce que
c'était au contraire simplement parce
que vous vouliez qu'on fasse attention à
vous je crois que c'était ça je crois
que c'était pas un réel désir de d'être
actrice ou de jouer quoi que ce soit
c'était
enfant vous aviez pas spécialement le le
désir de faire comme votre mère je crois
pas
alors vous avez commencé d'une façon
très très marrante un jour Jane Birkin
s'en va et laisse un petit mot sur la
table et les Chouraqui cherche une ado
de tournage vas-y pour voir vous y allez
vous êtes choisis c'est génial ces
paroles et musique j'ai jamais pris de
cours non j'aurais aimé
je suis sûre que j'aurais pris du
plaisir à le faire mais j'ai pas osé et
après paroles et musique vous avez voulu
partir en Suisse dans une pension alors
que finalement votre mère est Kate vous
disait c'est détestable n'y va pas c'est
insupportable les pensions vous êtes
parti un an dans une pension en Suisse
et vous l'avez assez bien vécu
je l'ai très bien vécu je pense que
j'avais envie d'un truc rigoureux et
Xavier besoin d'autorité il y en avait
pas assez à la maison
tu as déjà envie de passer par les mêmes
choses que ma mère que ma sœur et de me
contraindre moi-même à j'ai besoin de
alors Serge Gainsbourg disait en parlant
de vous charlotte est une orchidée
déguisée en ortie de moins en moins de
moins en moins ortie de plus en plus
orchidées c'est vrai qu'avant vous étiez
d'une timidité maladive là vous avez
l'air beaucoup mieux quand même ça s'est
arrangé
un peu dans le silence avant vous étiez
un peu angoissé non
angoissé j'étais très très timide je
faisais pas d'efforts pour pour lutter
contre on va voir comment
[Applaudissements]
Charlotte Gainsbourg
[Musique]
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te remercie Claude pour m'avoir fait
pour m'avoir laissé faire ce film
voilà
Claude Miller elle remercie Claude
Muller
[Applaudissements]
un peu comme ça à la tête dans les
épaules et tout là vous êtes un peu plus
j'étais jeune
à l'époque vous disiez souvent je suis
pas une vraie actrice comme ça si ça
marchait pas vous auriez pu dire c'est
pas mon truc c'est ça c'est pour ça hein
maintenant ça y est vous avez bon c'est
pas on sait jamais avec ce métier ça
peut s'arrêter
ou non
non
de tout recommencer
puis comme vous savez pas quoi faire
d'autre vous recommencez alors
Ivan vous a décoincer quand même non
pour la prépa de ce film je parle il
vous a il vous a fait dire le texte à
haute voix il vous a eu des séances le
travail très très intense drôle
maintenant quand j'y repense mais mais
difficile
de
il voulait que je me sente libre sur le
tournage donc il voulait que j'aille
trop loin peut-être en préparant et de
que j'ose mais c'était même dur devant
lui d'oser faire des choses surtout que
c'était dans un petit bureau je sais pas
terrible encore plus c'était pas non
plus chez vous à la maison il voulait
que vous soyez un personnage heureux
bien dans sa peau et c'est vrai que dans
le film d'ailleurs vous êtes vachement
légère quoi oui oui il voulait que je
sois que je sois ouverte que je sois gay
ça ça vous a aidé est-ce que votre
psychanalyse vous a aidé aussi à vous
décoincer
sûrement tu finis maintenant que vous
avez fini la psychanalyse
jamais fait moi j'aimerais savoir
comment ça se passe
non si jamais fini je pense qu'en fin
c'est fini mais j'y retournerai
je l'aurais besoin sur moi
ça m'a
ça m'a permis de enfin je sais comment
faire j'ai des solutions
vous savez où il faut aller chercher la
solution maintenant ça veut pas dire que
j'y vais mais je sais comment faire
un meilleur rapport avec votre image ou
simplement vous y pensez plus je m'en
fous je m'en fâche pas si je m'en fous
je suis un tout petit peu plus détendue
c'est moins grave qu'avant
c'est vrai que étant enfant vous
ressentiez un petit peu être le vilain
petit canard de la famille vous dites
j'étais entouré de de Jane de Kate de
loup doyen de bambou et vous étiez un
peu malheureuse complexé ou malheureuse
pas malheureuse complexée j'étais très
complexée parce que je pense que dans ma
famille la beauté c'était quelque chose
c'était important là il y a des scènes
dans le film vous êtes parfait vous
savez là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Charlotte Gainsbourg on va voir où vous
en êtes sur le plan psychologique on va
faire une interview qui va mesurer vos
peurs et vos angoisses on la bouche pas
pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Charles Gainsbourg donc interview peur
bleue
est-ce que vous avez peur des critiques
non non mais je les lis pas
est-ce que vous avez peur de prendre la
parole devant une salle entière
est-ce que vous avez peur de prendre
l'avion
non de moins en moins en fait devant une
grande salle
d'attente certes mais quand même c'est
toi qui prend l'avion
est-ce que vous avez peur des souris
est-ce que vous avez peur d'assumer vos
fantasmes
est-ce que vous avez peur de ne pas être
à la hauteur
vous avez perdu 100 même
est-ce que vous avez peur du noir
du vide
plus recommencer à flipper
si vous avez peur de manquer
de manquer
non je crois pas non si vous savez pas
trop ce que ça veut dire c'est que toi
tu as peur de manquer bien sûr comme
tous les anciens pauvres
de l'entraxe
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez peur de moi
pas vraiment je vous fais plus peur vous
m'avez jamais fait peur c'est de moi de
manger de beurre
[Musique]
du tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu